Peta Murgatroyd exits Dancing with the  Stars over a medical emergency  the 29 year old dancing pro will not  compete on the ABC shows upcoming 21st  season because she needs surgery the  star told People magazine she's getting  an orthopedic procedure that will keep  her from dancing for six to eight weeks  news/peter calls  devastating the MRI showed I had four  torn ligaments and a floating piece of  bone at the back of my ankle I knew I  needed to put my health first if I  wanted to keep dancing on the show into  my 30s PETA had already started  rehearsing with her would-be celebrity  partner country singer Andy Grammer but  could tell something was quote not right  still she plans to sit in on his  rehearsals Dancing with the Stars at new  season premieres September 14th